tells gobert to clear it out
mitchell oh he punches it home
that's a big mistake and how about the
adjustment as grant comes over
step back three heat check three-point
ball game murray
into traffic tough step back because
that shot
mechanics is pretty and then obviously
the tough shot making ability
here's mitchell a chance to close out
the half with a nice layup
atoning for the turnover on that pass a
moment ago
mitchell coming up on the toyota
halftime
jay on db's
great bounce pass inside to go bare for
the layup tremendous finish and this is
what i'm talking about utah as an
execution team
today such the drag screen mitchell
splits it
up high in a terrific pyrotechnic
he's deserved it donovan mitchell
carried your team in the second quarter
do not relax don't take your foot off
the gas
keep attacking off the triple and i know
he prides himself
now on the growth he's made as a passer
right now they need both
[Music]
settles for the three good jobs crushing
them in the offensive
rebound category and second chance just
getting absolutely
multiple looks mitchell causes confusion
great time inside
and gobert makes the catch for the slam
necessarily an easy catch
he is downhill in a hurry the shovel
pass
keep your pivot foot down rudy wow was
that a back court
that's what quinn schneider was saying
murray for three
got it hatched here again exclusively
two-man game rejects the screen
puts the as good a start as he had he's
disappeared here a little bit for the
time
murray butter hurry
around the oak screen hit him with the
hesitation move murray
oh he's on fire al murray has created
for you he's got a longer defender on
him than joe ingles
but boy oh boy what a possession
three-pointer
jamal murray stayed between him in the
basket
boy berry feeling good offensively this
time defers to jokic
i mean this is a big time delivery the
connection
is real their chemistry is true
33 in the game for jamal murray
[Applause]
mitchell with a little get back got it
a minute to go off the yoke it's screen
got free
raising up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
20 seconds to go mitchell on the drive
foul that they're going to count the
bucket
still just adding to what has been a
spectacular day
yeah fouled on the gathering absolutely
fouled on the gather just make
minor adjustments to take away some of
those easy
open looks that denver was able to get
the drop off back to yokis little
floater
and utah six of eight in the early going
approaching the midpoint of the first
quarter
joking she'll tee up the triple and drop
it through
you could just have everybody leave and
have jokic play ingles one-on-one right
now
murray's saying hey we're up three
diamond mitchell's saying okay a lot of
attention on me we're only down three
where is the game clarkson another three
inside two minutes remaining in the
first half
step back and rattling that home
performance right now for utah
[Applause]
and mitchell to step back denver got
game one
in overtime jazz trying to even the
series mitchell down the lane with a
kick out
catching shoe three they made five
straight threes
it's just mitchell getting all his
teammates involved
hurry trying to answer and he does so
jamal murray
responds but man murray is saying all
right it's my time to go
yeah that time o'neil just a little off
balance but it was a handoff again
downhill
directing traffic with porter jr on the
switch
two men to take the ball out of his hand
shot clock at three there's the skip
pass
oh neil out of the corner and there's
the adjustment
for the jazz you want to send two so we
could see exactly watch the double team
okay right here
just that little step up by royce
o'neill
okay allowed the pass to get there utah
jazz
you lose a heartbreaker in overtime this
kind of response has been impressive
mitchell for three i told you the ball
would come back to mitchell when he had
an opportunity to score
you need something and you need it in a
hurry heading into the fourth ottoman
mitchell
he takes the take advantage of the
three-point shot but then
on the deck on the attack the middle was
open he's 1-1 the first one was an
overtime win
and that was denver and jamal murray who
opens with the jumper
game two though inhales that rebound
ingles to mitchell good eye contact in
the hammer by donovan mitchell
donovan mitchell to get right behind him
easy pass
easy play for donovan mitchell inside
you see the late rotation
by porter jr good cycle to jeremy grant
his three [ __ ] out
gobert couldn't grab the rebound but
here comes mitchell in motion
donovan mitchell all the way to the iron
to put it up and in
jamal murray downhill on goldberg right
to the rim
oh my god a right hand spike against a
rudy gobery went right by him well you
do
you do see it if he's that far out on
the perimeter his lateral move
go bare inside donovan mitchell likes
that porter junior matchup
his three-point stroke has been
incredible
great defense that time by murray oh
what a block
and murray taking it right back and then
mitchell answers with a block of his own
yeah he kind of waited he knew murray
was going to come back to him he's
intelligent enough to know to get
himself on balance and then make the
play
donovan mitchell has had phenomenal
third quarters
he hits the three and it took some time
too for this team to kind of make the
adjustments beautiful middle pick and
roll again to
jokic when you for your actions and it's
not just what you talk about it's what
you do
you know on and off the court oh jokic
threw it right to mitchell the former
slam dunk champion this time just that
little bit of pump fake a little bit of
space and dunks on the defensive player
that's a nice dark heap can you believe
that and he brings a lot to the party
offensively as well the way he cleans up
the glass
as the roll man as well mitchell kicks
it
nieng that one's good
be a decoy find an open man donovan
mitchell shakes porter and perry's the
jump
this is where they want to get him
rattled a little bit mentally
yeah and to really pass it back to the
big fella the high-low passing of these
two big should be awesome tonight
inside go bear
timeout on the floor 233 left the
two-man game
with gobert and mitchell pass shot clock
ticks down to three
murray lets a runner pass down it goes
jam
and now murray goes all the way murray
scores
and this is why coach malone wants his
team to secure the rebounds not give up
any offensive rebounds
plumley finds murray shot clock down at
one it gets up
in time and counted this out
oh nice nice you freeze that big man
back there and because plumley's there
and you know if you pass it to him he'll
finish it strong
you have to honor that fake
fall down and stay down see webb that's
the key for this team to get back up on
their feet and it starts on this
possession
you're exactly right jared and i what
i've realized from what you're reporting
has left the bubble to seek a second
opinion
on his injury and hoping that ultimately
his right
knee gets healthy and and once he rehabs
and gets that second opinion we'll have
more updates
gwen snyder who ended up going to duke
and that's how that all began with larry
brown
danny of the miracles team that's tory
craig inside
as he scores for denver and they're back
up five
going under a minute in this second
quarter step back three murray hill he's
got another one now you got some time
if you talk keeps going to that
pick-and-roll the utah guards have
gotten anywhere they wanted to
morris all over donovan mitchell forces
a turnover
jokic pushes bounce pass morris all the
way
right in about that spot that donovan
mitchell just cashes one in it's a big
deal that's a big deal
he had a couple of jams and this one had
one right away as we started in the
first quarter
here's mitchell taking on jokic quick
release on the lay-in
and that was by the nuggets so it's been
a tightly contested game thus far
top for gold bear donovan mitchell
sending it way up in the sky and gobert
powers it down
this again you get into a space look how
far nobody you don't have anybody
deflecting or trying to get in the way
of the pass even more impressive than
the dunk was him
catching that i mean gobert is so
short-handed down there great pass right
there by mitchell thought it was too
much on it
three-point answer on the other end
murray
is roasting right now denver down four
under five minutes to go in regulation
here murray fires again
and murray hits again
look at this pick out front the great
set by jokic
and he didn't get a charge on the way
you love that coach schneider told us it
was such a difficult decision because he
wanted to be a part
of this playoff run so he's certainly a
part of them getting here for sure as
murray
hits a huge three for denver right back
in it has got to go quick murray hits a
long one here he'll have 50.
he's sitting on 47 he'll pull the three
he's got the three
50-point game first time in history
opponents
score 50 a piece but this one belongs to
the utah jazz as they run
out of his mind the other night 50
points trying to single-handedly
get them back in the win column there is
rudy gobert
to give utah the early lead and it's
been interesting since conley has come
back he just
hasn't seemed to be into the offense
he's kind of lost his rhythm offensively
mitchell steps into a deep three and
buries it
mitchell around a screen hounded by
murray takes some contact
and he's headed to the free-throw line
[Applause]
well he gets in the lane murray holds
his
nicely done here comes murray slicing
his way through the defense
and denver denver one of the best
offensive rebounding teams in the league
great save by millsap there
and he's going to try to walk it off
first field goal from millsap mitchell
got it
another look see jokic is up but he goes
the other way
drives away from the pick 17 of their 23
bench points
have come from clarkson tonight he has
been magnificent
murray taking flight puts it down boy
challenges go bare
at the rack to a dozen porter outside
murray
deep three get it
pass from porter murray steps into a
wide open they're right there they're
still in shouting distance
in fact you scored nine of their last
11. niang
off the bench sister the night little
give and go action jokic
back to murray and that was a thing of
beauty and then a tough drive right here
going at rudy gobert getting to the
other side of the ring there he comes
down the paint
knocked out of his hands well played by
dozier outstanding individual defense by
dozier
murray the relentless drive and he's
brought denver with
inform here's a young guy pj dozier
getting it going with his defense great
defensive plays by pda
pj dozier murray inside incredible
jamal murray with a stroke of genius
majestic second round
here's murray off the inbounds splash
brendan malone the first head coach of
the toronto raptors
there's a steal porter ahead of the
field to murray
runs out of real estate but gets it to
porter what
vision by murray and he is carving them
up
make it 28 after that last sucker
mitchell
mitchell here just gets by everybody
half-hearted health by michael porter jr
this is donovan
mitchell you can't stay on the side
you've got to get your
body between him and the basket what a
finish
donovan mitchell unlim
around the horn engels left open
well short rebound porter and mitchell
the steal
inside go bear in here though
you need the ball at this point
and everyone waiting with baited brett
to see where he goes here murray
the drive the kick jokic splash
star to star and we will be watching
brian anderson chris webber jared
greenberg will have the call coming up
next
on tnt final 20 seconds
here's a three by mitchell and he banks
it in why not connects for the first
denver basket is remarkable efficiency
for jamal murray and watching mitchell
and murray
go at it in this series has been a
thrill
mitchell he fires from three and he
rattles one home
what a start timeout michael malone he's
right with you chris webber for
six a couple of threes
spider mitchell gets his first of the
night it's 15 to eight utah
one night long good move mitchell
working a two-man game of gold bear
and look at jokic already backing up
mitchell goes right by them all kicks it
to the corner
wide open niang knox take to the basket
by nicole yokic
nice footwork right there by the big man
mitchell a little hesitation at a finish
at the rim
spider this is how you follow that
offensive lineman into the paint
into the hands of murray gets a screen a
three-pointer is up and in
point game utah on top this is game six
utah denver see what this second unit
along with murray can do inside
the athletic plum he just clears the way
for murray for the nice layup the blow
by by jamal murray now you're healthy i
think he's inspiring all his teammates
and i'm not going to ask too much of
gary harris in transition here's murray
a little hesitation
and the reverse is good with the block
murray
finishes on the other end with a reverse
defensive rebound and murray on the
drive
murray is fouled and one than the
starters
they're more athletic with porter and
plumley they attack the basket more and
when you have a more athletic lineup or
you know guys that are more
up on that three-point shooter oh good
move murray boy
still able to keep control of the
basketball and a little oh murray he's
doing it all the only thing he's doing
eight for ten
22 points four for five from the
three-point line yeah
it's the first half still he's been
electrifying tonight he's got 22
already and now murray again
oh neil to the line yeah he's sizing him
up these two have been going
at it and sometimes others like george
floyd who have lost his life in a police
shooting
so fellas guys on the court getting it
done on and off yeah no question that's
good stuff there jared thank you as
grant finishes on the law
mitchell turns the corner with milsap on
his hip and
mitchell with the layup he changed you
talk about
shifts and talk about shifting getting
inside the euro step over the two big
fellas trying to get it to go down he
does
mitchell guarded by monte morris harris
back on the floor as well
three-pointer is up for mitchell and
he's got it come on kind of had an
awkward step into it but found the
rhythm somewhere on the way up
harrison porter joining jokic and murray
on the floor now the denver five behind
the back jokic
fires up a three and off the window it
goes
in other words this was not on purpose
oh man i knew you had a prologue to that
but sometimes i tell you what when
you're good
murray patient now he's got gobert on
him
step back three on the way is good a
pleasure to have
a defensive stopper on your team just
look at this look at him moving his feet
and yeah i mean that's just better and
mitchell flies high for the rebound
nine point game utah trails eight minute
mark
in regulation and donovan mitchell score
the basket and won
murray mitchell show once again we've
seen it all
series long so explosive and if one of
our eyes
grant a part of his game that he was not
known for knocking down threes
mitchell for three another big shot for
donovan mitchell
[Applause]
shot clock to seven mitchell's got grand
on him mitchell a little step back three
is good what a shot donovan mitchell
with a big hit
murray three-pointer is up and it's good
you have to credit
you have to credit james harden not many
people in this league have their own
moves we can go through them the hook
shot and they averaged
nine and a half turnovers when they get
more than nine they lose
denver has been doing it on the
defensive end again in
in the three wins the jazz have had
under
10 turnovers turnover turns into a
three-pointer and
denver stretching this out to a 14-point
lead
mitchell with an answer
jazz aren't dead yet turnovers for 14
points and
you want to answer talking about ar
mitchell and murray
is off the charts right now step back
three on the way
and he's got another one jamal murray
man the step back hand in the face
murray here
jokic finding murray murray does he got
another one in him oh you bet he does
and that might be the dagger for another
three
he said last year he did not play the
way that he wanted to play in the
playoffs he wanted to make amends for it
he came out here focused crazy i had
that same feeling
mitchell's been a little bit quiet until
now with the easy slam off
he's got to get going mitchell has only
taken five shots
has two points murray floater got it
jamal
jamal murray was looking for the call as
well
shot clock down to eight mitchell
double-teamed
forced that one up and got it to go if
you're a coach you say give it up you've
done your job you've done your job pass
the basketball
good shot good shot
got murray on the switch forced it up
and got it to go
donovan mitchell sensing something
brewing back in this ball game
trying to will his team this is good
defense tough shot by donovan mitchell
rory diokitch the floater on the way and
a soft touch
nicole jokic gives denver a two-point
lead